on va faire un hardi view
alors vous pensez à quoi en ce moment
j'ai un peu peur de tes questions
quand vous regarder dans la glace le
matin vous dites quoi
je parle rarement à moi même le matin
tueur et aimer ressembler à qui quand tu
étais petit
vanessa paradis ah ouais je les adore
depuis tout le temps toujours ouais t'as
plus belle histoire d'amour
en ce moment ah ouais mais moins pour
vivre heureux vivons cachés on va dire
ça comme ça ouais
est-ce que tu serais prête à tout
quitter pour le grand amour ta carrière
tu es parents la france ta religion
oui ah oui
oui mais je pense que si même il ne
demandera pas
quand on demande un autographe tu signes
ou quoi ls
je suis pas comme ça les gens peuvent
s'imaginer que ce programme de l'usiné à
nice
quand est-ce que tu as pleuré pour la
dernière fois lors c'était à cannes pour
la projection de marie-antoinette tout à
fait pleurer et huawei mais pourtant il
la tue pas dans le film oui mais aussi
pour ça que ça m'a fait pleurer tu vas
et messieurs j'ai adoré ah ouais ouais
c'est la première personne que je vois
qu'il images avaient lu l'autobiographie
je sois j'adore sa vie cette femme est
comme ça et c'est vrai que le film
trouve que c'est déjà d'une beauté
incroyable et oui j'ai été très ému je
sais pas pourquoi
qu'est-ce que tu changeras en toi si tu
avais une baguette magique
j'essaierai de transformer mon angoisse
en sérénité
mais peut-être que je m'ennuierais plus
sais pas quel péché qui vous tente le
plus
apparaissent
et oui et je le sais et je le sais parce
que frédéric maladie
qu'est ce que vous pourriez vous avez
plus négatif sur vos bons en ce moment
j'ai accepté des sacs gratuits pas mal
c'est un petit peu honteux donc j'essaie
de les donner
d'accord c'est assez négative c'est bien
six lettres vie était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous changeriez
sans doute de l'adolescence parce que ça
arriver tôt ça a duré trop longtemps et
c'est un âge que je trouve très ingrat
je recommencerai pas ça ouais quelle
insulte qui t'a fait le plus mal à part
madame beigbeder qui fait
je crois que c'était à l'école c'est un
prof qui m'avait dit que
qu'avec mon nom j'avais pas besoin de
faire des études et c'est pour ça que ça
m'a appelé c'est parce que sa vérité
blesse qui est tu le plus envie d'épater
dans la vie
mes parents
on est qu il amer oui quand le téléphone
sonne t heureuse ou agacer
ses dépens quel nom s'affiche quelle est
la dernière chose que tu fais le soir
avant de se coucher le roi
l'amour
ça défile aujourd'hui je prends tu m'as
contient pas de film
qu'est-ce que tu ferais site rester 24
heures à vivre
pareille pareil pendant 24 heures
d'accord quel est le surnom qu'on te
donne que tu es quoi non je suis obligé
de dire ça
c'est new new new new york c'est
horrible l'union
c'est comme ça tu pourrais éviter de
m'appeler comme ça bon elle s'ennuie
à non je dirai pas qui ment tout à
refaire un deal j'étais veut dire on
s'appelle pas non non non
c'est compris mieux
qu est la dernière personne que tu as
envie de tuer moi
quand tu dis toi tu parles de niaux
et dieu dans tout ça
j'y crois pas ah bon mais
je pense à ça qu'il ya pas longtemps
j'ai dans mon pas j'essaie de réciter
notre père c'est bien comme endroit
c'était bénitier géant c'est bien ça
c'était non mais ça part d'un bon
sentiment très bien ce que tu vois ce
que tu as fait du bien ouais continue
d'essayer qu'est ce que la vie vous a
appris être heureux c'est maintenant ou
jamais j'ai peint le présent le bonheur
c'est maintenant ou jamais
comment aimerais tu mourir c'est pas
comme dit morrison dans un bain
quel est le mot que tu ne supporte pas
d'entendre pargneaux bien fait
j'ai craint le pire avec une force
commencé clearstream ah ouais parce que
je trouve ça laid entendre les uns que
pal français
ça me confiant qui comprend pas très
bien ce qui s'est passé en fait rien
jamais non plus
fait pas tout seul est-ce que tu as
menti pendant cette interview je suis
comédienne
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux